the reason we need to travel to Mars and
to establish a civilization on Mars is
to protect the long-term survival of the
human species we need to become a
spacefaring Society and eventually we
need to move far beyond Mars not only
from our own solar system but in to
other solar systems within this galaxy
and other solar systems in other
galaxies we are making wonderful
progress finding other earth-like
planets and we will continue to find
many of those in the future eventually
the human species is going to disappear
that means everyone who's a human being
will die eventually and this species
will die out and go extinct and there
are a number of reasons how that could
happen and why that could happen
including a large asteroid hits earth
and destroys everything larger than a
rabbit has happened in the age of the
dinosaurs 65 million years ago or
eventually our Sun begins to die and
that that is a 100% probability our Sun
will begin to die in about two billion
years and one of two things will happen
either we will earth will be thrown
completely out of its orbit and goes
spinning off into space and everyone
will die very quickly or the Sun will
essentially irradiate earth as it
expands because what happens with a
dying Sun is it gets very large and so
in order to survive as a species we have
to become a spacefaring species we have
to get off this planet eventually and
that is the long term hope for Humanity
Mars is the most habitable place in our
solar system by far and even though it's
an incredibly hostile environment we've
developed the technology over the last
50 years to survive on Mars and to
survive quite readily so Mars is a
wonderful first step it's where we go to
learn how to go farther Elon Musk says
he will land on Mars in 2025
we've had he and I have had a number of
several conversations about this
he's more optimistic than I am in the
discussion with him about a time frame
and when a SpaceX rocket or two might
land on Mars we kind of came to the
conclusion that maybe we should say 2027
in other words giving him a two-year
fallback but he specifically says and I
quote him on this in the book he will be
extremely disappointed if a SpaceX
rocket has not landed on Mars by 2030
and I think that's quite reasonable
I'd give 90 percent odds to a betting
person that a SpaceX rocket will land on
Mars before 2030